how's it going guys today we're going to
look at
colliding spheres
and we're going to look at the code
behind spheres now spheres are one of
the easiest ways to do
collisions in 3d
because the rotation doesn't matter when
you use squares or rectangles or
capsules
the rotations of the matter and it gets
a lot more complicated but if you're
just using spheres
it's very simple so i just want to show
you that and show you a code example so
that you know how to use it
and it works the same in 2d so all you
really need for your collider sphere is
a center
and a radius and if it moves all you
have to move is the center which is just
a point
glm vec3 in case you don't know it's
just three floats in this case
and x y and z in 3d space
so what we have here is just a very
basic structure in c
plus plus and that's what we're going to
be working with
so as you can see here if we instantiate
a new collider sphere
all we need is a location and a radius
and
that's it so let's look at the
instantiation here
so if you give it a location a radius it
just sets those
and if you don't give it anything we're
just assuming zero for the center
centered at zero zero zero x y z
and the radius of one that's just how i
have it in my code
let's move on to the handling of it so
now that you know what a collider sphere
consists of just the center and a radius
how do you actually handle it so that's
what we're going to look at next
so i've got this function here that
returns a boolean
and the function is called sphere versus
sphere and it takes
a pointer to a sphere and a pointer to
another sphere and
let's go look at the instantiation of
that we'll also look at this point one
this point versus sphere
which takes just a point and a sphere
but mainly we're looking at sphere
versus sphere
so i'm the sphere versus sphere
so you have to pass it in to spheres of
course
naturally so we have the main one and
the other one
and we're doing this by const pointers
just to make sure they're not
changed and a pointer is a very small
piece of memory so that way we don't
have to move around a whole lot of
things we could do it by reference
but it would be essentially about the
same as a pointer
okay so the first thing we're going to
do in our code
i guess actually before i move on the
point of it being a pointer here is so
that we can check if it's null
if it were a reference the null check
would be a little different
so we don't ever want these to be null
so we have this initial check just to
make sure neither
are null now this is kind of verbose
code it could be written
simplified and you don't have to put
equal equal i could put like if not
sphere
or not other getting a little c
plus stuff there but that is also legal
to see if they don't exist
okay so what we want to do is we want to
get the distance
from the two center points and we can do
it in this method
this i think is about the fastest way
you can do it math wise
you know we're using multiply here
because it is faster
than divide in general so all we do is
we get the center of 1x
minus the center of the other x and we
times it
by itself again center of 1x minus the
center of the other
so we just times those together and we
do the same for the y
and the z and we add those all together
and then we square root the whole thing
and that gives us the distance
of the center points and then all we do
here
at the end is we want to return a
boolean of true or false true if it
collides
false if it does not so it's the
distance
if the distance is less than the sphere
radius plus the other sphere radius
then it collides if it's greater than
then they're not colliding and it's
that simple so that's all we do the
point is
just about the same we just don't have
to mess with
the radius of both of them so you get
the distance
between the point and the center
and then you check if that's less
than just the sphere radius so point
versus sphere and sphere versus sphere
are
probably the simplest colliders just
because you don't have to think
about rotations at all
at all so when you get into those other
ones
that's where it gets complicated and for
now in my
engine that i've been writing i'm just
using spheres because they're simple to
write
and well the other ones are simple if
you're not doing rotations rotations is
where it gets complicated so let's look
at an example of the sphere versus
sphere
i have been building this little
asteroid thing
with this code and in here i have a
check collide
function that runs every loop or every
update
and all it really does is it calls
sphere versus sphere and it passes in
two spheres one of them is our laser
and the other one is our asteroid go in
this instance
is my little acronym for game object so
everything with the go is a game object
so we get the kaleidosphere of our laser
we get the collider sphere of our
asteroid which goes off the edge here
and if i return if it returns true from
this whole if statement i know it looks
weird because it's multi-line but it's
just so long that i split it up
so if this returns true then it says
first asteroid hit
and say we do the second one too we just
have a check for each of these asteroids
basically
against the laser and that's all it does
so let's go ahead and run this
now note that i'm just using the cl for
now i don't have them actually exploding
or anything that's something i'm doing
later
so uh yeah some debug info there but
if i shoot my laser you see it passes
through this one it says first
asteroid hit it actually spams it a
bunch of times because it registers a
whole bunch of times before it passes
through
it doesn't like doesn't break
so to speak and code and same with the
second one and i've just got a tiny
little sphere on my laser
and i've got spheres about the size of
these wrapped around those
so that's just to confirm that it works
now what i should do is on the first
detection of a hit
i should like to spawn my laser and
make a little effect happen but instead
it just keeps going because
i just don't have anything in the code
to say that but that's just to show you
that the sphere versus sphere
works in this manner i hope you enjoyed
this episode about
collider spheres and and maybe it'll
help you out if you're
trying to figure them out i love them
because they're just so simple to work
with
and just not having to deal with
rotations is super nice
thanks for watching we'll catch you in
the next episode
peace out everyone and also as a last
little note here this is actually not
for my normal viewers
someone was trying to get a hold of me
from
a company and i can't email you back
because your servers are rejecting my
emails
it's not really anything i can do about
that but yulia if you wish to continue
working with me
unblock my emails or i don't know
get old me some other way i'm not sure
i'm not maybe give me a link to a
discord or something
i'm not sure what else to tell you i've
tried to email you three four different
times
i'd like to work with you i don't want
you to think i'm ghosting you
but i can't help that your server is
rejecting my emails